-And, finally, guys,
it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ "WeTweet" ♪
♪ "WeTweet" ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that
we should post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you
five different tweets,
and we're all going to vote on
whether you
like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats?
Yep. I can tell by the utter
confusion that, yes, you do.
You guys, you can vote for all
of them if you'd like.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want to do.
We're gonna see the results
live on the screen here.
Higgins, Roots,
you have your clickers, too?
-Got it.
-What is your record, Higgins?
Are you pretty good with this?
-I think I'm pretty good.
-Yeah, yeah, I think you're --
You're, like, good.
Tariq? 50/50?
-I think I'm the champ.
-Quest, you just say...
-Yes to everything.
-...yes to everything.
Okay, yeah.
Here we go.
Whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out
live on the show
so that you can all like it
and "WeTweet" it.
-Oh!
-Yeah. Thank you.
Alright,
you guys ready for this?
First tweet is...
-Wow.
♪♪
-Wow!
-Yeah.
Like, maybe they can't
relate to that? Maybe?
The alarm goes off
when you're making toast?
Alright. People are very --
-I'd say lowball.
-Yeah. Yeah, I don't feel
confident about this one.
-I feel like this one's toast.
[ Laughter ]
-You laugh at that one?
They laughed harder at that one
than they -- Alright.
The votes are in.
Let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
Oh, wow.
Oh, it's right down the middle.
Wow. Alright, let's go to
this next one.
They don't necessarily
get better, by the way.
Okay, here we go.
This next one is...
♪♪
-I like that one.
-Yeah. You go, "I think I'm
gonna go home with that one.
Yeah, that one's for Larry?
Yeah, perfect."
Alright, let's see
the results on this one.
I think it's gonna be better.
Oh!
That's what I'm talking about.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally.
-129.
-I feel like that one's
got a chance.
-Yeah. That's in the park.
-Yeah.
What was the first one again?
I didn't mind the first one.
It was like, "I wish the
fire-alarm button had --
'Sorry, I'm just making toast.'"
-Just making toast, yeah.
-That's hilarious.
-Yeah.
'Cause you laugh about thinking.
-It happens to me all the time.
-Sure, but toast or is it, like,
a steak or something or dinner?
-Toast.
-Toast, really?
-Sure.
-When you're at home,
you put the toaster on.
-Yeah.
-Your toast burns so bad
that plumes of smoke come out?
-That's correct.
-Okay.
Well, then I think you need
a new toaster.
-Alright, let's try
this next one.
Let's see if this one's good.
Alright, here we go.
Next one says...
♪♪
-Come on, that's good.
-Yeah?
-Yeah.
-The splits?
-Or, like, a split?
-Just doin' them all the time.
-Do the splits?
Do you call them "the splits"?
[ Laughter ]
You think that's funny?
-I think it's funny that you --
Yeah, you call 'em --
-That someone would call it
"the splits."
-"The splits."
-Yeah, if I could do
the splits...
-Yeah, like that.
"I bet you can't even do
the splits."
-No, I can't do the splits.
Alright, let's see
the results on this one.
Alright.
-Whoa!
-Wow, yeah, very judgmental.
The audience
knows what they want.
They know what they want and
they know what they don't want.
-Yeah.
-They don't want that or toast.
I understand.
-It was 103.
-Next up, it says...
♪♪
Yeah, yeah.
-"Don't watch this, kids!"
-"That's pretty graphic.
We can't fast-forward this?"
-"No."
-"Alright. Oh, okay.
Alright, let's take a break.
Alright, good.
Let's go to the kitchen,
make some toast."
Let's see the results
on this one.
-This has got to be a big one.
Yeah!
-Oh!
That's what I'm talking about.
-There you go.
-That's what I'm talking about.
Thank you very much.
I think that's gonna be
the champ.
-I think it's gonna be
the winner.
But do you like this next one?
-I do like this next one.
It's pretty great.
You can't vote twice, though.
This is all real time.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, we're all
experiencing this --
This is a shared experience.
-Ooh!
-We'll have this
for the rest of our lives.
-Aww!
-Here's the last one. It says...
♪♪
-That's more of a truth, yeah.
-What do you think?
I think it's got a chance.
-It's got a chance, but it's not
gonna beat the other one.
-What was the other one? 168?
-Yeah.
-It won't beat it, right?
-No, I don't think so.
-Yeah. Let's see the results.
No! No, by one!
By one, it did not win!
[ Laughter ]
By one vote, it did not win.
We went with the movie scene.
We're going to tweet out
this one right here
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a "WeTweet," and enjoy.